what's going on everybody it's Warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things Marvel and MCU
and in the midst of all the hype for
Spider-Man no way home and the upcoming
films like doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness Thor love and
thunder and other huge movies coming out
this year we finally have some news
about a certain group that everybody has
been waiting for Marvel's first family
the Fantastic Four we have an update
from the director himself John Watts who
recently directed Spider-Man no way home
so he did a great job with that so
hopefully he brings that to the
Fantastic Four which I'm sure he will
but he recently gave a tiny update about
the Fantastic Four in a recent interview
and we have some insiders providing some
information about the cast as well when
we can expect an announcement and amidst
all of this there are some casting leaks
that apparently got out that suggest
quite a bit of an unusual cast listing
whether or not it's true who knows but
I'm excited to be talking about the
Fantastic Four I think it's one of the
most anticipated projects coming up
within the next few years from Marvel
Studios so let's dive into it but first
if you are new to this channel be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos and be sure to
hit that notification Bell now in a
weird way we kind of have Spider-Man no
way home and Final Destination 6 to
thank for this tiny little update about
the Fantastic Four variety did an
article about John Watts and Final
Destination 6 and Spider-Man no way home
of course they're talking about how much
money Spider-Man Noe home has made so
far and how successful the film has been
and they talk about how the Final
Destination franchise could be revived
with John Watts but here's where we get
our really good Fantastic Four News the
article made sure to State this very
plainly it says John Watts is only set
to produce Final Destination 6. his next
directing gig will still likely be
Marvel studios's reboot of the Fantastic
Four superhero franchise which we
remains undated now this news comes
right in the middle of the rumor that
the Fantastic Four the MCU Fantastic
Four is set to break in production very
early in 2023 and this all is lining up
so far because if John Watts is going to
be a producer on Final Destination and
Final Destination 6 is set to come out
in 2022 that frees him up to direct the
Fantastic Four which in case you didn't
know and I should have mentioned it by
now it is confirmed John Watts will be
directing the Fantastic Four but that
makes him free to direct it or start the
project in early 2023 and get this there
is actually an unknown movie title slot
at the end of 2023 in Marvel studios's
lineup now originally when Marvel came
out a while ago and they released their
entire production timeline all the way
out to 2023's end there were actually
three Untitled movie slots they all had
release dates but there was no name for
the projects however since Marvel
Studios in October recently laid the
bulk of their upcoming slate essentially
pushing all of the movies back they
removed two of those upcoming Untitled
projects however they left one Untitled
project in the November 3rd of 2023 slot
and if you consider this fact right here
this slot is most likely for the
Fantastic Four at Disney's investors day
they announced all of their upcoming
projects in the Fantastic Four was one
of those projects announced and out of
all of those movies The Fantastic Four
was the only one announced that doesn't
have a release date set to it so it
would be logical to think that this is
for the Fantastic Four and if we combine
all of these facts together it does seem
like that is the case rumor has it that
production for Fantastic Four will begin
early 2023. according to variety John
Watts's next directing gig is going to
be the Fantastic Four and if it does
begin production in early 2023 that is
plenty of time to make a movie for the
November 3rd Untitled release date for
2020 3. so it looks like we might not
have to wait as long as we thought for
the Fantastic Four film which is
obviously awesome on so many different
levels one we finally get to see who the
cast is which I'm actually about to talk
about in just a second but two once the
Fantastic Four come that means the X-Men
shouldn't be that far behind them
because if you think back to 2019 San
Diego Comic-Con where Kevin feige first
revealed Marvel space force light he
mentioned the Fantastic Four and he also
mentioned along with them mutants in
which he said in an interview later on
that mutants and the X-Men are
interchangeable he means them as the
same thing I didn't even have time to
talk about the Fantastic Four
and there's there's no time left to talk
about mutants
but you know what all that stuff's been
rumored you've heard about rumors and
now it's finally time it looks like in
2023 in November but who is going to be
the cast for The Fantastic Four well
recently there has been a cast leak
going around and like I said it's pretty
interesting check this out and I should
also note that the Twitter account main
middleman who has a very good track
record when it comes to leaks stated not
too long ago that they heard the
official cast of The Fantastic Four will
be announced soon they said they believe
sometime between early and mid next year
which is now 2022. they continue to say
by soon I mean on MCU time where
everything is always well planned anyway
I believe only the cast will get
officially confirmed and the names I
heard there are famous names and
unfamiliar names but I can say that most
of them are very talented so let's talk
about this casting link this leak we
have no idea if it's true or not but I
kind of like who they have for Sue storm
for Sue Stone form AKA The Invisible
Woman they have Kristen Bell most of you
probably know who Kristen Bell is she's
in for getting Sarah Marshall Veronica
Mars the good place and I think as far
as image goes for Sue storm she fits the
bill and she has really good acting
range so I think that she could probably
pull off the invisible woman just fine
and if she can nail kind of the athletic
ability of the Invisible Woman I think
she could absolutely crush this roll now
for read Richards we have Glenn Howerton
which is a very interesting choice and I
think most people would know Glenn from
the show It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia he plays Dennis the show is
phenomenal I love it's always sunny and
Glenn is an incredible actor but of
course this role would be completely
different than pretty much anything he's
done it's definitely different from
Dennis but if he could nail this role I
actually think this would be a pretty
good casting for him now for Johnny
Storm AKA The Human Torch we have Chase
Stokes not gonna lie I had no idea who
this was until I looked him up but he's
one of of the stars of the show Outer
Banks and just judging off of how he
looks not off of his acting abilities
because I really don't know them he
looks the part I think he could make a
good Human Torch and like the leak did
say from Main middleman the cast is
going to consist of famous actors and
not so famous actors but I think
everybody is going to know this last
name for Ben Grimm aka the thing this
leak has Seth Rogan listed to play the
thing now I had to wrap my head around
this for a little bit when I first read
this and I'm sure a lot of people are
going to have to as well keep in mind
whoever plays the thing is going to be
wearing a bodysuit it literally doesn't
matter if the person who is going to be
playing Ben Graham is jacked or not and
honestly if this were true who's to say
Seth Rogen couldn't get in shape for
such a huge iconic role but my point is
it doesn't have to happen it's gonna be
a suit or CGI or whatever they can make
him look however they want to make him
look the real twist to this would I
think be having Seth Rogen play him for
a comedic aspect of the film and I think
as long as it's not over the top I think
it would be pretty good because you
gotta remember there's a lot of
bickering and bantering between Ben
Grimm and Johnny Storm and Johnny Storm
provided a lot of the comedic relief in
the original Fantastic Four films who
was of course Chris Evans so if you have
an unnamed actor coming in you probably
want a big name actor coming in to
provide that comedic relief or at least
play a pretty significant role in it
which is why I think they might have
chosen Seth Rogen for this part but
again this leak is not confirmed by any
means it's just made its way around
online but what do you think of this
it's quite an unusual cast but if it
were true Marvel typically knows what
they're doing I don't think they've
really cast anybody wrong but again let
me know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below how excited are you
for Marvel's first family to finally be
making their way to the MCU don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news for live updates you can follow me
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
watching wolf wolf